look folks don't fall victim to
subjecting yourself to this this
conversation that law enforcement is bad
that law enforcement is the enemy of the
citizens that were sworn to protect and
serve we swore an oath NNN Oaks we swore
to support protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States and
the government and that were duly
qualified under the States Constitution
to hold office that is for me as a
sheriff for these men and women as
deputy sheriffs and we end that with so
help me God but God is absent from the
media's message or black lives matter or
any other group out there that's that's
making themselves respectable disrupting
what we know to be our quality of life
in this country
in Clay County we have a great quality
of life